Dear colleagues, I am
extremely pleased to welcome you to
Ukraine today in Kyiv.
Your visit is taking place on an important
day for Ukraine, the day of Europe. This is a powerful
signal of support for our
European integration aspirations of our state,
our society, and a clear sign of
continued fruitful cooperation
between Ukraine and the European Union.  I am
grateful to you personally for your leadership in
supporting Ukraine. We greatly appreciate your
efforts in implementing the ambitious
agenda that exists between us between Ukraine and the
European Union.
for us, the times
are convinced that all decisions
made by you these days bring
Ukraine closer to the realization of our ambitious
goal of full EU membership.
discussed with you the remaining steps
in order to fulfill everything fully
convinces you that Ukraine will fulfill all
its obligations.
Today we are in fact at the
final stage of implementing the seven
recommendations to achieve sustainable
results of the documentation of the recommendations, we
closely cooperate with the European Union at all
levels and in
fact in  within the framework of the visit of the mission of the
Venice Commission to Ukraine on
May 4-5, at the highest political level, the
issue of the
implementation of the recommendations on the adoption and
implementation of the legislation on the procedure for
selecting judges of the Constitutional Court of
Ukraine and the implementation of anti-oligarchic
legislation and the protection of national
minorities was discussed in detail. These are important things that we really
talked about in detail with  by the Venice
Commission during their visit, we are currently
improving the relevant legislation adopted in Ukraine
regarding the
establishment of a competitive procedure for
the selection of judges of the Constitutional Court, as
well as all other steps that have been discussed with the
Venice Commission and which are an
important
direction of work for us in the implementation of the seven
recommendations.
that Cher
[music]